Imagine your manager comes to you
and asks you to build a several platform
for your new e-commerce application.
So you start building a few lambda
functions, and after 3 months,
you build hundreds of lambda functions,
which becomes very hard to manage.
In this session, we will serve serverless
development practices to confidently
scale your lambda applications.
Hi everyone and welcome to CNS 372.
Several several patterns for large
scale applications with AWS Lambda.
My name is Lefteris Carraer Yu.
I'm a senior solutions architect with AWS
and I'm thrilled to be joined by Michelle.
Hey everyone, I'm Michelle Chisman, a senior solutions
architect. I'm also at AWS.
Now, when companies want to build or migrate
their applications to serverless and
AWS lambda,
they usually start by mapping
one functionality to one lambda function.
We call this single purpose lambda
functions.
Let's take an example of an e-commerce
use case where we might have
the following architecture.
Now in this architecture we see a few lambda
functions. For example, we see a lambda
function to get a product,
to add something to our shopping cart,
to get something from our shopping cart, or
remove some something from there,
or we have a few lambda functions to actually
purchase something. So we go
through a series of steps which is
submitting an order, reserving
the inventory,
processing the payment, or fulfilling the order.
Now, all these lambda functions
are backed up
by Amazon API gateway, which
serves as the front door uh
for our API layer.
And we have a few endpoints
there that actually are
integrated and called the lambda functions.
Now it's lambda function
is also saved to a different
dynamo DB table. For example,
anything which has to do with products,
it's saved to a products table or
anything that has to do with cards is saved to
a card
uh cards table in Dynamo DB.
Now, this approach of having
one functionality mapped to one
lambda function is perfectly fine.
And many companies do exactly that.
However,
as customers grow and add
more features,
they end up with hundreds and
sometimes thousands of lambda functions.
And this introduces 3
major pain points that we hear
consistently from our customers.
The first is
how do I properly structure
and organize many lambda
functions like hundreds of lambda functions.
The second one is how do I reuse
code across those functions?
And the third one is how do I
maintain consistent deployments
across different environments,
meaning development, staging,
or production.
And this is exactly what we're going
to solve during the session.
By the end of this talk, you'll have practical
patterns you can apply
immediately to your serverless application.
Now, let's tackle the first problem.
How do I properly structure and
organize many lambda functions?
Now, in this session, I'm going to use Quiro,
which is our new genic AID
that is based upon
Visual Studio code.
And is now generally available for you
to use and it's really awesome.
So here I have all the lambda functions
I showed you at root level in
separate folders. So let's take a look.
We have for example the Act
lambda function here which is
which has a very basic uh functionality
so what it does it's actually getting an input
from Amazon API gateway it is
validating the input.
It is creating
an order,
uh, a cart item to be saved to Dynamo
D B, and it goes there
and saves it.
Nothing fancy, very simple one, the
same with remove cart as well, right?
So you remove something
from Dynamo D B
or the get card
you get.
A card from Dynamo to be
based on a card ID. OK?
Nothing fancy, very simple lamb
functions.
I also have here a template
YAML,
which is a SAM template.
Now SAM stands for serverless
application model, and it is an
open source framework,
which makes it easy to build serverless
applications.
It is, it is essentially an extension
of cloud formation, and
it consists of two parts.
One, you can write your infrastructure as
code, as we see here in the template
YAML.
And the other part is that you can
use CLI commands
to help you with local development, testing,
uh, and deployment as well.
Now, for example, some CLI commands you
can use with SAM to help you with your serverless
applications. You can initialize
a new serverless project using the SAM in it command,
and this will create a code base you need
to start working with uh
with serverless applications.
You can do some build to build your project.
Whatever programming language you might be using, if
it's Java Python, it will build it for you.
It knows how to build it.
And also you can do deploy
where you can deploy your serverless
application to AWS to AWS.
But now let's do,
let's let's take a look at the sam template
that we have here.
So it's a very simple sam template
which. Creates
an Amazon API gateway over
here. And all the lambda
functions that I showed you
we have a root level.
For example, you have the get card
lambda function here.
And you also create
an API gateway endpoint
that is integrated with this lambda function
with these five
lines of code,
OK? So we have here all our lambda
functions.
And at the bottom we have
the uh Dynamo DP tables
as well.
Now, you can visualize that one by
using uh.
The appli
the infrastructure composer.
Over here
So you see I have all my lambda functions,
I have my dynamo DB tables,
and I have my API gateway and
the endpoints I expose.
OK.
Now, this code base is deployed
to a single git repository.
I have already deployed that
to my account, so let's run some
tests against some endpoints.
So I have created a test script here.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to
call my test script,
and I'm going to do
the single purpose lambda functions that we have here,
and I'm going to add something
to our Dynamo DB table using
the postcard
meth uh endpoint that I have in
my uh API gateway,
OK?
So what this does, it's actually doing a curl.
Which is sending like a a payload
there. Now, as you can
see, I've added something to
my Dynamo DB table using the
lambda function I wrote,
and it took 1.2
seconds to finish.
If I run that again.
I'll see that it takes 0.2
seconds to finish, so it's much, much
faster.
So why is that?
Because of the cold starts.
And the what, so what is a call start?
Call start is essentially the initialization
time
it takes for a lambda function
to download the code
to start up the environment, the
runtime environment, for example, JVM
if you're using Java,
right? So prepare this execution
environment as we call it
inside a micro VM.
And then run it
so this initialization time,
the first time is called the cold start. Now
the second time this is already warmed
up, so we won't incur a cold start
again, OK?
I can also do a get
here
now since this get is another lambda
function, then I will incur another cold
start, right? So this also takes
1.3 seconds to finish. If
I do it again,
I won't see the call start. It will be much, much
faster, 0.3,
OK? Now,
in our code, we have only a few
lambda functions,
but if you have 50
or 100 or 200 lambda functions,
this becomes really unmanageable.
Now, the code base is going to grow,
and you will have a single git
repository, you will have one
massive CICD pipeline,
and if anything breaks,
everything is at risk.
So what is the solution to this?
We are going to apply the microservices
principles and the bonded context
to our serverless architecture.
Now, let's take a look at those
card functions that we have here, the add
card, the get card, and the remove card.
Now they all operate on
the same domain, which is the shopping
cart. They share the same
data model, the same dynamo DB
table, and they are likely owned by
the same team.
Now let's group those into
a separate folder.
So let me create like a new folder,
which I'm going to
name it card service,
and what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
get the car, get card method.
I'm going to move it there.
I'm gonna get the remove card method
and. Move
it there as well
and I'm gonna get the.
Out card method and move it there.
So now we have a card service folder
and all the card related functions
live here.
Now you will apply the same principle
to the other functions,
so everything that is related to
the inventory you will create like a different
folder and put, put everything there.
The same for orders, the same for payments,
the same for products.
Right? Now, since we have applied
the microservices principles,
then we need to split the resources
into multiple repositories.
So for that, I would have to create
one sum template
for each microservice and repository.
So what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to create
a new template here inside
the card service folder.
And what I'm going to do is.
Inside this template YAML file,
I'm going to take
only the card related
function,
lambda functions.
Um, the Amazon IBA gateway API
and the Dynamo DB
card
table only
so.
I'm going to remove
everything else
from here.
And I'm going to live
here only.
The 3 lumbar
functions.
OK. Now,
this um template is much more clean
now. Usually in a
microservice architecture
you don't expose the databases
or anything that is related to the data
directly but you do it through APIs,
right? Because in here
what you could do is you could
output something from your some template.
In order for other templates
to have that as an input,
so for example, you could output
here the cards table or even
the lambda functions, but you don't want
to do that in a microservices
architecture.
You want everything to be exposed
via an API.
OK.
Now,
the benefits of this, it's uh
it's service now
can be developed, deployed, and scaled
independently.
It can be owned by different teams
and. The shared
dependencies no one else
will be using,
OK? And this is
how you actually scale the surveillance
architectures organize uh
organizers
organizationally, OK?
Now, as I said, this card
service will be deployed into
a different git repositories.
OK, and you will do the same for
all
the domains that you might have in
your microservice architecture.
Now let's run some tests
against this new card service,
let's say microservice that we have. I
have deployed that to another.
AWS account
so. I'm gonna
do again some tests and I'm gonna
do like a test.
A micro
ad.
Will we see any change?
No, right? It will be exactly the
same
because we have
again 3 lambda functions.
We have a call start for each lambda function,
so we'll see like the same,
um.
Duration for its lambda function,
OK?
So 1.3 to add something,
1.3 again to get something,
OK? So
although we've done some optimizations on
the organization level, we haven't
done any optimizations on the lambda
functions.
Now, we'll talk about an optimization
technique
for lambda, which is to reduce the
actual number of the lambda functions
we have.
A pattern that is gaining traction is
called the lambda web adapter.
Now, instead of having one
function per HTTP method,
you can run a traditional
web framework inside your Lambda
function and write route
requests internally.
Now let me show you how you can do that.
So what I'm going to do here, I
am going to merge
the add card and the remove card
into
a single manage card function.
OK.
Now I already have.
My code here
So let me do that.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going
to remove the ad card.
And they remove card
because I'm going to create a single
manage card function
and I'm going to put it under the card
service.
All right,
so let's see what we've done here.
Now, in order for the Lambda web adapter
to, to work,
you have to use
a library
that you can run a traditional
web framework inside lambda
function. Here
we are using FA API
which is a very commonly used
uh library for Python, and
we are using also Mangum
as the web adapter for fast API.
So what we are actually doing here
is the following.
As you can see here, we have
one function,
which is the add to cart function,
which. is
getting all the requests from Amazon API
gateway from a post method
slash card,
and we have also another lambda function
which is.
sorry, uh, we have also another function
in here, another method
which is.
Getting all the requests from API
gateway through the delete
card
endpoint, OK?
So this lambda function is actually
getting
from API gateway
to end points into a single lambda
function.
Whereas in the previous
example, we had
one entry point.
For our 2 lambda functions.
OK.
Now, so from 3
lambda functions that we had the add
card, the get card, and the remove
card, we're now down
to 2 lambda functions.
Now, same functionality but
less infrastructure overhead.
Now let's run some unit tests
to see what we have achieved.
I'm going to clear that.
So I'm going to do test again.
I'm going to do the adapter,
and I'm going to add something into
our.
Dynamo debatable.
So now the response took 2.8
seconds to complete.
Whereas in the previous example it took 1.3
seconds to complete. Why is that?
Because now we have a bigger lambda
function. And if you, if
your lambda function is bigger because you have
more libraries and the bigger
deployment size,
then the call starts will also
increase. So be aware
that the deployment size really matters
for the for the call starts
in your lambda function for the initialization
time, OK?
But the cool thing about that now is
that if I do a remove.
Since the add method and the remove
method are in the same lambda
function,
now the remove method will
not incur any call starts.
So we have now 0.2
seconds,
which is much, much faster.
OK? Now, the benefits
of using
a web adapter
is that you have fewer call starts as we
saw, so we have one function
to keep warm instead of two.
Uh, you can do like shared initialization.
So if you do like database connections
like SDK clients, these are initialized
just once,
right? You can use familiar
patterns,
for example, you can use fast API,
you can use Express, you can use
Springboot if you're a Java developer
or any web framework you know,
and you can plug it in into Lambda.
And it's also easier
to test your Lambda functions,
because the routing logic
is inside your lambda function,
you can mock everything or you can
use uh unit test
within your lambda functions.
But be careful,
don't create a monolith.
With these web adapters,
so if you have let's say
2030, 100 functionality
within your lambda function, you'll have like
a huge deployment. So
don't create a monolith.
Keep your functions focused on
the bounded context, on the microservices
principles.
Now, uh, try to also monitor
your function size and the memory
all the time.
And consider that one lambda function
failure might affect also multiple
operations if you use the web adopters,
OK? Now
some factors to consider when
doing this merging and using the web adapters
are the following.
If you have common codependencies,
you can merge your functionality into
one lambda function.
If you have common downstream
dependencies, you can do that,
right? You can group your functions
based on the initialization time that you
might have
or the memory configuration that you want
to configure to your lambda function.
Or maybe your IM permissions
you might want to to set
to your lambda functions, OK? All
these are like good examples
to consider using the web adapters.
Now, a very common scenario
that customers use Lambda for is
also to transport data
from API gateway
to the downstream services.
For example,
let's take a look at our get
card
method. Here
All we do here is
fetch data from Dynamo
DB and return it
to Amazon API gateway.
We have no business logic. We are doing
no transformation. We are doing nothing, just
fetching something and returning it.
Now, we can optimize that
by removing the lambda function and
replacing it
with what we call API gateway
direct integration.
So what is a direct integration?
Direct integrations allow Amazon API
gateway to directly communicate
with AWS services
like Dynamo DB,
step functions, or others
without needing an intermediary
lambda function.
Let's do that for our get card function.
So what I'm going to do is
delete the get card function because I
don't really need it.
Because I'll replace, I will replace
it with
a direct integration
from Amazon API gateway,
and what I'm going to do,
I'm going to get my template
from here.
And I'm going to
put it in here
and replace it with visual.
So let's see what we have here.
So we have our Amazon API gateway
like we had
in the previous one example,
but now what we see here
is that whenever we're doing
the get end point from here,
what we are doing, we're calling
an Amazon API gateway integration.
And the integration is
against Dynamo DB
and what we're doing, we're actually calling
an API from Dynamo
DB which is the get item
API.
So API gateway.
Directly calls
an Amazon Dynamo DB API,
which is the get item API.
It
sends the payload.
That we had
and it also constructs the
response as we see here.
It uses a language
VTL is called,
which actually creates
the response
from the Dynamo DB uh response that we had.
OK.
So let's run again some tests
and see what benefits we have in the in the
get uh card method.
I'm going to my test script again.
And I'm going to do
test
direct integration and the get method.
So now what we see here,
we see first of all,
we don't see any lambda invocation here
we call directly dynamo the B. So what
that means we don't see any cold
star, right? So we see
the first time we call that is
0.2, which is amazing,
right? So the benefits here
are significant.
You have a lower cost,
so you don't have any lambda
invocation charges.
You have lower latency,
you have one less hope in your
whole request path.
You see no concerts because FBI gateway
is always warm,
right?
And you have also better scalability
because you
have no lambda concurrency limits
to worry about,
right? So when should
you use this pattern?
You should use it
when you're doing simple crowd
operations, create,
update, delete operations.
You can use it when you have
no business logic or validation,
or you want the absolute lowest
latency and cost.
Right, but try to avoid
it when you need like complex
transformations
or business logic is required
on you or you need like error handling
beyond the HTTP status codes, right?
So I'm gonna take one question there,
yeah, we indicate.
Counted from a 3
to serve any request.
Uh, so S3 really
exposes APIs. You can expose an
API from S3, so I wouldn't use
API gateway with S3 directly with
S3. Uh,
I do need uh MLS authentication.
MTLS authentication with that. OK,
so I'm not really sure if you can
do it with S3,
uh, but, uh, I mean, maybe a gateway direct
integration has like more than 100 integrations,
um.
That's definitely one I think to dive into
after the talk.
Yeah, we can look into it, yeah.
So, uh, let's recap what we've done
to solve the the first pain point,
which is like organizing
the lambda functions.
So we went from many scattered
lambda functions in in one
git repository,
to a microservices and bounded
context approach.
In a multi repo
architecture.
We went to
fewer lambda functions using
the lambda web adapter
pattern and to zero
lambdas for simple operations
with direct uh with the Amazon API
gateway direct integration
and you can do the same for the
other lambda functions as well. For example,
the get product, you can do the same
API gateway direct integration and
remove the get product lambda function
entirely. Yes.
So, uh, you from the API API gateway,
there's like, uh,
time out of like 30 seconds, right? Like if
you are using like a lot of functions, 29 seconds,
yes, 29 seconds, yeah, yeah,
yeah, so I mean
that you can, you can, you can make it higher, right?
Yeah, this is a soft limit nowadays, so you can
like, yes, increase that 3 support ticket,
yes, yeah, with direct integration
if you have like a lot of function in between and
you change it to be a direct integration.
No, because 29 seconds is the
API gateway timeout.
Lambda functions have a timeout of 15
minutes. But 29
seconds is uh
API gateway.
So, what we've solved
is how to properly structure and
organize many lambda functions.
OK, so.
Let's say we've built now
8 different lambda functions.
And
whilst writing those lambda functions, you've realized
that actually, you've written the same database
connection logic, like 15 different times.
Does that sound familiar to anyone?
Yeah,
um, this is one of the complexities that we
have when we start having these isolated
lambda functions,
because they sound brilliant in principle.
Um, but when you've got the same thing
that needs to happen across multiple different functions,
you're ultimately having
code duplication.
So in this section what we're actually going to
talk about is how we start to reuse
code across functions and to try
and reduce that code duplication you might find
across your code bases.
Is it all coming up now? Excellent.
OK.
So the simplest way is to obviously have
everything as a single purpose function, um
an isolated unit.
And as we just mentioned, this can lead to duplicated
code, um, which isn't particularly
efficient.
When you're becoming aware that you've
got that duplicated code, you panic
and you start throwing multiple different
features into the same lambda function to try and
reduce
that duplication, because they need the same connection
logic. So it makes sense to have lots of different
database connections in just one lambda function,
right? Um, but then that leads
to other complexities.
Um, so if you do have
15 duplicated
database connection logic,
and you need to update that,
you've now got to find every single instance
of that connection logic in your code
and update it to be
what you need it to be.
And
that, that creates a mess, and no one
loves doing that. Everyone hates that. That's the boring
part of programming, right?
So this is why code reuse matters, we
want consistency and we want reliability
across all of our code bases and
across our deployments and our code.
If we've got authentication logic
that's in just one location,
it means that our author is handled
the same way across every single lambda function.
Likewise, if we're doing error handling,
and that's centralized, we can then make
sure that our error handling is done
exactly the same way across all of our lambda functions.
So if we're talking about code reuse, then
I'm sure a few of you have leapt to the conclusion
of what it is we're going to talk about now, and
that's lambda layers.
So lambda layers are ultimately
a shared library that you can share
across
all of your lambda functions.
You can bundle into this layer things
like custom runtime, any of your dependencies,
and you create that layer once,
but then have multiple lambda functions use
it. So it's a really, really
powerful way of bundling together
all of that code that you might need to use multiple times.
So
to show you this, I'm actually going to
leverage a lambda layer that already exists.
Um, you might have heard of this layer already,
and it's called Power tools for lambda.
This is actually a really cool lambda layer, um, an
open source um toolkit,
um, because it bundles a load of serverless best
practices into your lambda function, and
you can utilize them right there.
So things like um logging and monitoring,
um. There's these
best practices already there, and I really encourage
you to go and look into this in more detail,
um, because it's super useful, but I don't want to get
sidetracked in this talk,
um, talking about it.
So
because this lambda layer already exists, when it
comes to our template here with our lambda functions,
all I actually need to do is add the ARN
to deploy it.
But obviously that's great for something that's third
party and already exists, but you might have
the dependencies that you want to bundle
yourself. But that's really simple to do
because all you have to do
is create a zip archive of the
things that you want to bundle within your lambda function.
And then deploy a layer as you would within your
SAM template, your cloud formation template, terraform,
however it is you write your own infrastructure as
code. And it doesn't have to be within the same
template, you can obviously deploy it in another template
and then reference the ARN um in another
stack. So
because I can't remember ARN's off the top of my head
to save my life, and this one is pretty
complicated, I am just going to copy this
one. I do apologize.
Um, and we're going to take this first lambda
function here.
Um, and we're just going to add the layer.
I don't want
conditions. Is anyone else getting really annoyed with the
uh AI suggestions in
um IDEs at the moment?
OK.
Right. So that's now a layer
added into our get cart function. And obviously this
is our SA template.
So we can go ahead and just do a SAN build.
Not for the comfort vile, thank you, AI.
And then that'll go ahead and build, and then I can do a quick
sum deploy.
Now you can give me a convict vow.
There we go. And
then that'll go ahead and run the sound deploy.
And once it's deployed,
that layer will be attached to our
lambda layer.
Um,
now, you don't want to see
that deploying. So instead, we're just going to talk a little bit
about lambda layers.
So there are some key things we need to think about with lambda
layers, because they're not a catch-all solution,
right? You can only have 5 layers per lambda
function. And that's a real limitation.
But
in, in.
Sort of relation to that,
we also have deployment package size limits,
and that doesn't change when you add a lambda, a
lambda layer, right?
So a zipped deployment
package
is capped at 50 megabytes, and
unzipped, 250 megabytes.
So don't think that you can just suddenly add
every library or every runtime
that ever existed into a lambda layer, and
you can deploy it.
Um, because of these deployment package size limits,
so you do have to be strategic
about what you put into a lambda layer. Don't put
everything in there, only put the things in that you need.
Lavderros talked a lot about cold starts in
the beginning of this talk,
um, and actually lambda layers do
impact your cold starts
because anything that you bundle into your layer
has to be downloaded,
um, on each fresh and execution
environment.
So if you've put in a really large
ML library,
that's gonna take a while to download and you're
going to see some increase to your cold
starts. And
then finally,
versioning, something to pay attention to, right? Because
versioning
can be an absolute
godsend. It,
you can do AB testing, blue-green deployments,
um. But you can
also get yourself into a very sticky
situation with versioning,
because say for example, function A
needs version
and function B needs version 2.
Well now you're having to maintain two
different versions of the same lambda layer
because two different functions need it.
So make sure if you are using versioning
with lambda layers, you're doing so
um in a well thought out manner to
avoid falling into those pitfalls.
Now, this is code reuse. This
is being able to use the same
code across multiple functions, but only writing
it once and only having it in one
location. And Lefteris has already touched
on a more radical solution,
um,
which is just,
let's remove code altogether.
So Lefteris talked to you about these SDK
integrations between API gateway,
um, and say, Dynamo DB.
Um, That's great
for a simple workload
that's just making that one synchronous
call. But sometimes you might actually have a
series of calls that you need to make.
So if we think back to this architecture
um that left error showed earlier, we have our
um order API here at the bottom. And there's a sequence
of things that need to happen
um in order to fulfill a
particular order.
But several of these are
still just making dynamo D beetles,
and we're using a full lambda function that's got
code that we have to maintain.
To do this
So there's a simpler way to achieve this, right?
So, um,
we can then use a step function here.
The step function can orchestrate these,
um.
These lambda functions.
And if I open my template
in
Infrastructure composer, as we saw earlier.
Um, it's not just adding infrastructure
to our template that we can do here, we can actually
add a step function resource.
So when I add this resource to this
um infrastructure composer workflow
here, um that actually updates my
template to include the infrastructure
as code for the step function.
But what's really cool is I can now open
Workflow Studio.
To now build my state machine right here
within the ID.
I like visual, I like to see things, and especially
step functions, where ASL can be quite
complicated to read and understand.
Um, this just helps me to understand things better
and see things better.
Sorry, bear with me, dry throat.
OK, so we can start building out then
our order
um process here.
So this first lambda function,
and that's going to be submit order.
Um, don't worry, I'm not going to make you watch me build
the entire workflow, um, because
no one learns anything from that.
Um, and then let's say reserve,
um, the inventory.
OK. Um, and we can go ahead
and just keep dragging these different
um.
Actions into our workflow to build
up the steps that we
want to complete.
So let's look at one I've already built
so that we can see this a little bit easier.
Um, if you have the AWS,
um,
add-on to, um, VS code or
any of your other IDs, um, you can actually
view all of your resources within AWS
right here in the, um, ID without having to
log into the console, which is really cool.
Um, so I can see here.
This particular step function and I'm going to open that
within Workflow Studio.
And you're going to open the workflow studio.
Aye, or not.
Try that again.
OK. Open
Workflow Studio.
Voila, there we go.
That's better.
So. Um, this
is one I built earlier, because nobody wants to see
me build all of this. But what we can see now
is the different steps of the workflow,
um, all of which are lambda functions. But we've got some error
handling. So if
payment fails, we can reverse the
process that has just happened,
um, so that we can release the stock that was reserved,
etc.
Um, and we can trigger some events so that
if we've got another microservice or another bounded
context, in this case,
maybe we want to just take a stock check to
see whether we need to order more stock now that that item's
been bought.
Um, but as I mentioned, these are all lambda functions,
and we want to get rid of code.
Um, and if we're going to create an order, that's really
just writing something into a dynamo DB table
and creating an order ID.
Um, so we can actually just
search for actions here.
And we can put
a Dynamo DB.
Option.
Right here,
Potitan. It's
getting a bit small now,
sorry, all right.
OK,
so um we can then configure the
item by clicking in
um to the inspector. And we can configure
what the step's going to be called,
which table we're going to call, and so on
and so forth. And we can start to just
replace each of our different lambda functions
um as we go through. Now
something like take payment, we don't want
that to be a single SDK call. There's a lot
of catches that we need to do,
um and error handling we need to do within that lambda function. So
that makes sense to remain as a lambda function.
But this means that if we replace all
the different lambda functions
with direct SDK calls,
we've massively reduced the amount of code
that we even have to manage.
Um, I know that as
developers and as coders, our job is to write
code.
But we don't always have to. And
sometimes it's easier to just let these managed
services do what they were designed to do.
Um, and, and do those direct integrations.
Now, SDKs aren't
replacement for business logic, as you can see,
and as I mentioned,
something like taking payment, it still makes sense
to have a lambda function for that.
So you still have your important logic
and your important workflows written in code,
um, with all the checks and balances that come with that.
Um, but we can start offloading some
of this lighter lifting to
things like SDKs,
um, to be able to.
Pardon me,
um, to be able to make our lives easier,
ultimately.
Question. Yeah.
Does it make sense to pull out, like
if you have a dynamo call in that business logic,
does it make sense to pull that out and
and have it call a lambda after that
step function for that business logic?
So it depends what you're doing. And ultimately,
when you're using a step function, it's not
the Dynamo DB call that's going to be calling that lambda
function afterwards. It's just an orchestration mechanism,
right? So you're just saying which step happens
next.
And that's powerful, because then you, you've
got a definitive.
Pathway that's visual
um to say we know exactly
what's going to happen in what situation,
you can use the built-in error handling, the
retry logic, and without having to
write that all yourself,
but still have it be as reliable
as it would be if you were implementing it in
code. OK.
So that's code reuse.
So
We've talked about how we can reuse code
across functions.
But I actually now want to take a step
back away from code altogether,
just a little bit.
And I know this is a code talk, but sometimes it's
important to think of the bigger picture.
And in this bigger picture,
what we really need to think about is our account
strategy when we think about deploying our lambda
functions, and not just lambda functions, but
actually all of our infrastructure or all of our
code. Um,
How many of you deploy um your
workloads to one account for
all of your development environments, you know, dev, test
prod. OK,
I'm preaching. OK, I saw, I saw a hand
at the back there.
Um,
very, very,
um,
shyly put up there.
Um, and I'm guessing then everybody else
is, is deploying everything to different isolated
accounts.
Excellent. OK, so I'm going to preach to the choir here then.
Um,
so there, there are reasons to have
everything in one account. If you're a small startup, it's
easier to put everything in one account,
um, because it's easier to manage. If you're not
deploying an awful lot, you've only got maybe one
small application,
you don't necessarily want to start deploying
everything to multiple accounts.
Um,
but.
There's a major risk
with deploying everything to one account.
Um, and the, the immediate one is
if someone compromises your account,
that's a problem because they've now compromised
everything in your account,
including prod.
Um, but also there's just the human element, is if
somebody makes a mistake,
they can accidentally take down prod just because
everything's in one account.
So
A multi-account approach
is also on the table where we split out
everything into multiple accounts.
But that has its complexities too, right?
If you split everything into its own account,
um,
it can be more complex to manage. And again, if
we're talking startup size, maybe that's not
such an issue. Maybe you've only got 10 accounts.
Um, but I work with global pharma companies.
And I can tell you they've got something like 400
accounts that they're deploying things to.
So we get a completely different level
of complexity to manage.
However, you've got isolation.
And there isn't one right or wrong answer there.
Um, I personally, because of the size of
customer I work with, have uh prefer to
have that account separation,
but at a very minimum,
make sure your prod is separated from your testing
and and dev accounts.
So then any mistakes that happen in dev are
not going to affect your prod.
So let's say we do move towards this multi-account
deployment then. And we
want to maintain consistent deployments.
I think I've got the right room here. I don't
necessarily need to explain why we need consistent deployments.
I think that's really clear.
Um,
But in order to have those consistent deployments
across multiple environments and multiple accounts,
taking into account
everything we've discussed today about not wanting
code duplication,
um, we then need to start thinking about having dynamic
code and then building in that um
dynamicness into
our deployment pipelines,
um, so that we can um keep
our code bases, um,
manageable
whilst still
ensuring we're deploying the right things to the
right environment.
Again, I'm gonna bang the drum on reducing
code um duplication.
And so we'll look at how we can do that
within um our code here.
Oh. So
Um,
If we go to our template, then again,
um, you'll notice at the top, we have
this section called parameters.
Um, and this is really your first port of call
for making your code dynamic, to make it
react to various different situations.
In this particular case,
environment.
So we can have a parameter that takes in an
environment, and we can do simple things like that,
at like changing a function name based upon
the environment. So we can add a prefix or a suffix,
but depending on this input.
We can also do more
complicated things with this.
We can do um lookups
into maps to see whether
or not um the memory
um needs to change
based on an environment, or we can
um even decide whether or not a resource
even gets deployed.
So if you're deploying into prod,
you might want everything deployed, but if you're deploying it
into dev,
maybe you don't want some of that heavy
um logging and monitoring,
um, which costs a lot of money once it starts
running up into high volume.
So, let's look at mappings
then. So
a map,
and this goes not just for Sam,
but for cloud formation as well. And to some
extent, terraform, but it looks a little bit different in terraform.
Um, a map is essentially just a map,
a key value pair map
of um.
A key that you choose and a value you want
to associate to that key.
So in this particular case, I don't want conditions,
but we'll leave it there because I'm going to talk about that in a minute.
And if someone wants to tell me how to
completely erase AI from my IDE
after this talk, I would welcome that greatly.
OK.
So um let's do memory. So I want
to have memory set dynamically
in my template based upon whether or not we're deploying
to dev, or we're deploying to prod.
So I'm going to define a map called memory.
And then I'm going to say, OK, the
key of death.
Size.
And let's make Dev really nice and small,
12 8.
And then I want to do prod.
Again, now.
One day it will be useful.
And then,
let's say we want that bigger, we want that to be um
124,
when I can type correctly.
OK, so now we have our map.
So if we go into our
first lambda function, then, um
we can easily then fetch that value.
By going memory size,
find in map.
And then that is actually a helpful suggestion,
um, where we refer to the name of the map,
we refer to that environment parameter,
and then we pull out the size variable.
Um, and so when this runs at runtime,
and when it runs at deployment, it's now going to put
the correct value in there for the environment
that we're deploying to.
We don't have to have two separate code bases
for prod and for dev,
because we can accommodate for both of them in the same
template. Now,
if we want to determine whether or not a
resource is even deployed,
depending on the environment, we can use something called
conditions.
So conditions,
um. No.
You would think
it would learn.
OK, so conditions, we're going to
go is prod,
is this prod.
And we are going,
there we go. It's, it's helping.
It's helping.
Um, so we're going to say if the value
of the environment variable is prod,
this is going to evaluate to true.
If it evaluates the true, our resource will
be deployed. If it doesn't, it won't
be deployed.
And so what we then do is go to our land function
here. We do condition.
Um, and we just refer to that condition.
And so now,
This resource will only get deployed
if the environment
equals prod.
And so this means that we can make our templates really
nice and variable and dynamic. And
we can avoid deploying things that we don't need to deploy.
So when we're doing cost um reduction
or cost savings,
um, we can
control that all within the same template.
And the one final one I just want to cover, which is
SA specific in this template,
and that's globals.
So globals are really powerful because we can
set the variable at the the parameters
at the top of our template and it will apply to
every one of those resources.
So in this particular case, we've set some global variables
for our lambda functions.
So every lambda function will inherit the timeout
of 30 seconds. It's always going
to be deployed with the Python runtime of 3.13.
Um, and then we're going to give all these environment variables
to every single lambda function. So we define
those variables once, and they apply to
every function within the template.
Really, really powerful. And as I
say, this is specific to SAM. You won't
find this in cal formation.
Now, I'm
going to finish up quickly by just
Going a little bit further into how we then use
this dynamicness when we're actually using
deployment pipelines.
So
I like Git GitHub actions, um,
it's one of the favorite workflows that I like
um for deployments.
And when we're
thinking about deploying our workloads, what we
want to really achieve
is consistent deployments.
OK.
And so
we can deploy
um these dynamic templates
using variable files or variable
overrides using some workflow
definitions here. So this is what a GitHub actions
workflow looks like.
Essentially in here, we define when we deploy,
what permissions we deploy with,
um, and how we're going to deploy. So
in this case, we're obviously using SAM.
Um, and we pass in the credentials.
So in this case, I've created an OIDC provider
within my AWS account.
And then we give the instructions for how to deploy.
And as you can see here, uh we do
a variable override
um to set the dev environment.
Now this workflow is just deploying to dev, but
we could have this workflow deployed to prod.
And
what we can also introduce is a human
review gateway.
So we can do that deployment to dev,
and the prod deployment won't even begin until
someone's reviewed that dev deployment and made sure it
actually went correctly.
Sometimes with GitHub actions, it'll say it's deployed
correctly, but actually when you inspect it a little bit more.
It hasn't actually deployed,
um, it's just gone, yes, the action completed
correctly, which isn't necessarily always useful.
So sometimes having that prod human gateway
is really, really fantastic.
And then when you actually go
into
That's not,
there we go. So when we go
into GitHub actions, this
is what the workflow looks like when it's run.
So these were a few when I was setting up the,
the demo.
Um, Obviously, setting up credentials
is
often difficult. And so I had a few failed
deployments.
But every single one of these you click into,
you can then see a full, um,
you can see the workflow.
But you can also see the
every action that took place.
Um,
so you've got that full audit trail as well of
how it deployed, whether it encountered any issues,
and for each one of those steps.
If we go to the SAM build and deploy that same output
you see in the console, you'll see here in
the logging.
Um, so you're always able to check what's
happened. OK.
So
You came into this talk
and um we presented
you with a common enterprise challenge.
Um, you had lots of isolated land functions,
you'd migrated from a monolith, split them out,
and then realized that you had complexity.
So let's recap what we've actually covered.
So in the first part, we covered
organizing our functions.
Um, and we talked about whether or not to
have single or multi-purpose lambda
functions,
um, and, and the context within which that would
be better, and how we use bounded
context to start merging functionality
together. We
then talked about code reuse and how we can
use um lambda layers to
reuse code across our functions, minimize
that duplication across our code bases,
um, and if we want to go really
radical, remove code altogether
using SDK integrations. And then
finally,
we talked about consistent deployments,
using dynamic code
um and deployment pipelines.
So the key message I want to take away here is that
the these points that we're talking about, it's not
just about deploying landers.
It's about making sure that you're um you're
building scalable and maintainable
platforms
um that can grow with your enterprise needs.
So if I want you to do anything
after the talk, um, this talk, it's to go away,
pick one pain point, and then start applying
these principles that we've taught you today,
um, and see what happens. And if you wanna talk
to us on LinkedIn about anything,
um, after the, you know, obviously you're not gonna experiment
now. But if you do go away and experiment and you actually wanna
talk to us about it, reach out to us. Um, we're,
we're accessible and you can find us on LinkedIn.
There are other sessions, we've picked these sessions
specifically because you should still be able to make
them. So these are our recommendations
uh for sessions to go and um
look at and watch.
Um, and we also have some
other resources here.
So if you scan the QR code, this will take
you to a lot of surus learning
if you want to further your journey.
And with that,
I would like to thank you all, on behalf of both
myself and Lef Eris.
Thank you.